people now have your face tattooed um
because when people get the public eye a
lot of times they'll they'll just get
tattoos of like your face on their body
um have you seen that i i have seen a
lot of those on social media
um and you know uh i i think
usually it's it's more of a ron swanson
thing
um than a nick offerman thing
and uh i think that's uh that's a nice
compliment
but you know be careful when you're when
you're getting someone tattooed on your
body
you know humans are fallible even if you
enjoy what they've done so far
i may make you sorry uh down the road
that you have my face
on your calf that is exactly what i say
i'm like people be like look i got this
and it's like my face and like a lyric
and i'm like
you could hate me in like five years you
could be like she was remember when we
liked her
like you know and it's there but anyway
what if we go on a killing spree i know
well here's the thing
they're in luck if they got ron swanson
because he's fictional
so at least it's not real you could be
bad but ron swanson is still solid so
it's like but you're is so great yep i'm
still here
just waiting for you to subscribe if you
don't i'll be trapped in this box
forever